Justin and Haley Bieber aren't letting
any drama pop their love Bubble I just
don't want to like I don't want to read
stuff because I don't want to read
negative stuff and then be upset you
know over the past few weeks the
internet has been buzzing with
speculation of a feud between Haley and
Justin's ex Selena Gomez but a source
tells E.T that the Beavers are doing
fine and have no plans of addressing the
chatter Justin knows that speaking
publicly about it will only amplify the
situation and bring more attention to it
so they have been supporting each other
privately
[Music]
ET Source adds that they don't want to
deal with this repetitive ongoing former
relationship drama and are taking things
day by day because they don't want this
to be something that impacts them
negatively it means something to me of
course this all comes after fans
speculated Haley and Kylie Jenner were
making fun of Selena on Instagram after
cell shared this clip referencing her
newly done brows I accidentally
laminated my brows too much
shortly after that Kylie posted this
snap writing this was an accident over
her brows and shared a close-up pic of
Haley's brows but things came to a head
when a clip resurfaced online of hailing
gagging At The Mention Of cell's bestie
Taylor Swift full of the meanest lyrics
about a celebrity since Taylor Swift's
last album
after the clip blew up on Tick Tock cell
came to Taylor's defense in the comments
writing so sorry my best friend is and
continues to be one of the best in the
game following all that Selena announced
a break from social media this is a
little silly
and I'm 30. I'm too old for this so and
when it comes to sell ET Source says
she's staying in her Lane and doing her
own thing I always hope that the people
I'm involved with or of course support
me can just kind of spread love The
Source adds that she's dating and open
to love but is focused on maintaining
her health while still being attentive
to her fans Selena has been going to
therapy leaning on her friends and
family and keeping her Circle close I'm
really big on vulnerability I think
people are really scared to to be honest
with themselves as for any fans I think
Justin and Selena could rekindle their
romance
ET sources no chance that chapter has
closed for both of them
[Music]
thank you